ouais si michel serrault
c'est la fin
risque
le jeune homme au visage et que c'est
que c'est trop ça mérite pas ça vaut
mais c'est mérité six arabes ont assis
quand même ouais si si si si merci à la
alors messieurs 0
normal
non
franchement là la deuxième place et a
mérité l'an dernier là c'est tout mais
là il y en avait autant pour toi et pour
une démarche sur l'hommage et ça tourne
au foutage de gueule moi je
tu sais comme je t'aime toi c'est bien
réciproque c'est bien c'est bien à des
sols parce que oui a lui aussi monde qui
résistent surtout pas beaucoup de comics
c'est vrai série de comics qui trouve
grâce à théziers ya n'a pas beaucoup en
suis pas dans les ventes dans les dents
les vivants non bien alors michel
serrault donc le fameux sondage du
journal du dimanche qui donne le
classement des français préférés des
français
oui vous a nommé premier comédien
préféré défense mais c'est quoi ces
règles
m
quand on sait qu'un mentionnait que le
succès du journal du dimanche est sans
doute dû à la mini série de tf1 qui
s'appelle la sphère de mine ity
meilleures audiences de tf1 en 2003 12,2
millions de téléspectateurs 50% de parts
de marché alors ce qui est intéressant y
avait vraiment une osmose parfaite entre
entre vous michel serrault et le
personnage de gaston dominici
on vous a dit je pense qu'on avait
raison nous a dit vous ne jouez pas
dominici vous êtes 2 min tit b c'est la
vérité je suis dominici oui c'est moi
dominici et je vais passer en jugement
bien mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
souvent on parle des méthodes de l'actor
studio où les gens pour tourner
quelqu'un comme gaston dominici bon
celui des anglais ou en tous les cas
s'immerger dans la maîtrise et dans la
campagne voir comment on nourrit les
poules et et vous en fait michel vous
avez fait appel à des souvenirs
personnels n'avaient pas fait de pré
nolan et d'une manière enfin d'une façon
générale quand même je ne suis pas non
plus tu sais que j'ai tourné le dr
poteau jamais misé gros 16 ans j'ai pas
de chaudières à la maison c'est vrai
enfin il ya un tas de choses comme ça je
ne suis pas non plus dans garde à vue je
vais pas assassiner la petite fille
c'est vrai mais ce que vous dites quand
même et vous avez raison alors pour être
comédien
il faut avoir la mémoire des autres
peut-être pas si oui non mais croit que
pour jouer la comédie il faut prendre un
parti pris et je ne veux pas jouer avec
dominici poteau sans avoir à mon avis là
dessus mais sinon j'ai rien à dire je me
fais remplacer alors là il ya beaucoup
de réflexions de cette qualité dans un
livre que michel serrault publie chez oh
éditions
qu'ils s'appellent les pieds dans le
plat tu l'as lu alors c'était un journal
tenu de façon un petit peu irrégulière
parce qu'on n'a pas toujours l'occasion
de weed man
un peu au gré des événements comme
d'ailleurs nous posons on peut changer
si on veut changer les dates pour nous
et la réflexion n'est pas huit jours
alors on va rester dans le métier
d'acteur
si tu veux un vous voulez pas dans avec
un acteur qui s'appelle fabrice luchini
est un ami à moi oui vous dit fabrice
luchini m'agace ce qui vous agace c'est
fabrice luchini c'est qu'il a déclaré
reprendre pour la première fois le rôle
de la fnac de louis jouvet comme s'il
était l'héritier de jouvet et de son
talent alors que vous vous l'avais joué
300 fois la porte saint martin mais
trois ou quatre cent fois oui ça vous
choque un peu pour mieux laisser parce
que moi je les aime beaucoup il a
beaucoup de talent mais aussi les autres
parce qu'on pourrait croire il n'a
peut-être pas assez de mémoire
ouais je comprends il en a qu'on joue il
en a besoin mais pour des lingots culte
et ta prestation ça veut dire mais parce
que c'est pas grave non c'est pas grave
enfin en tout cas c'est rectifier dans
le livre ainsi rectifié puis surtout ce
que vous dites c'est que au sujet de
louis jouvet cette fois non plus de
fabrice luchini
c'est michel serrault écrit que louis
jouvet était un excellent et demont
comédiens personne va remettre 100
ingénieurs mais des kiss mettewie jouvet
à faire des analyses sur le théâtre ce
que fait un petit peu lui qui s'était de
l'esbroufé en fait cette façon
d'intellectualiser le théâtre ça vous
énerve quoi on parle de deux jouvet qui
était directeur de théâtre et il n'a
jamais aussi bien joué la comédie qu'au
cinéma
oui et alors ils disent est ce parce que
s'il y avait beaucoup de il avait génial
au contraire magnifique mais quand on
nous présentait avec huile il avait
horreur du cinéma avec ce que nous
connaissons moi je l'aï vu au théâtre
plusieurs fois j'ai vu deux fois dans ma
vie je veux tu es magnifique aussi mais
au cinéma
tout le monde connaît les prestations de
jouve est donc nommé lisais quand même
c'est l'heure des têtes de d'admettre
que le poulain compter du théâtre y
avait le cinéma où il était génial
alors voilà alors bon alors je parle de
ça parce que je vais vite j'espère qu'un
jour fabrice luchini redescendre à ma
portée parce que c'est là si je pouvais
jouer avec lui et qu'ils m'écoutent
oui j'aimerais bien parce que le le
principal pour un acteur je crois la
première chose c'est comme ce que nous
faisons en ce moment je me pose des
questions oui tu ouvres ses grands yeux
et oreilles et une écoute louis et moi
j'essaie de répondre oui
et en dira seulement au théâtre c'est
pareil il part donc est ce que tu dis je
parle et tu me réponds vous trouvez en
gros que quinine manque d'humilité quoi
c'est ça non je crois qu'il a été mal
élevés non michel serrault parle de
fabrice billy et puis à l'acteur qu'on
ne peut pas nommer par charité
chrétienne lors il se prend pour jean
poiret qui limite outrageusement premier
pas deuxième point ils jouent mal très
mal même
troisième point mauvais esprits mauvais
animerez jugement quatrième point
il donne des leçons de morale à la terre
entière se dit humaniste mais n'oublie
jamais son intérêt personnel voilà
dernier point il est fait pour les
tournées de sous-préfecture où sa fausse
élégance de parvenus peut épater les
casinos et enfin il a un avis sur tout
surtout dans le sens du vent voix mais
qu'il habillé pour l'hiver
je suis pas ok vous parlez moi je sais
très bien de qui vous parlez
oui il omet moi je pense avoir mais je
crois pas que ça puisse être lui parce
qu'il ya quand même des contradictions
accumulées à qui tu penses y va
oui mais des choses qui ne collent pas
du tout alors si c est lui et si c'est
lui moi je pense michel pardon je pense
qu'il joue très bien la comédie mais bon
ouais c'est la seule chose ou pas je
veux dire la vérité michel on pense à
pierre arditi en nous mais on se dit que
arditi jeu vachement bien la comédie
donc entre en ont mais c'est vrai quand
tous les cas vous vous êtes pas
contrairement à ce que vous dites de ce
comédien vous n'êtes pas dans le sens du
vent devrait plutôt les les pieds dans
le plat c'est le titre du bouquin c'est
l'ultime levée justifie à gland titre
par exemple vous ne comprenez pas moi je
trouve ça très bien de s'attaquer comme
ça aux vaches sacrées vous ne comprenez
pas très bien pourquoi tout le monde
adore jacques tati des c'est pas ça j'ai
bu a fait une moue deux ne s'étaient pas
convaincant dans la drôlerie way for
mais là c'est mon nom vous trouve ça
chiant vous endormez devant la télé et
je dis la suite et la suite après we
have et quand c'est positif vannes ou
non mais michel cmh mans bien que vous
disiez ça marche mais ça c'est violent
où il ya une espèce de consensus général
national c'est vachement bien qu'ils
aient des gens mais franchement victor
hugo c'est pas un peu de la merde écoute
j'ai pas lu à leur patrie vous n'êtes
pas plus tendre avec les hommes
politiques en parlent jamais mais je n'y
ai dit des méchancetés alors pendant ma
part un vous dit ingrat phare à quoi
vous dites il est pentue batik raffarin
on a un peu l'impression nous dit qu'il
tient la boutique avant la fermeture
c'est vrai c'est le comique
mais c'est pas mon sens on parle des
commis de l'état lui c'est le co mais
voilà il attend le patron alors là là où
ça va pas non là où ça va très bien
justement section des services publics
il faut que ça reste je suis autorités
de l'état je crois à ce que je pensais à
ça nous toujours une mule disais mais
pourquoi n'y aurait pas une armée privée
aussi bayern en irak on voit ce que ça
donnerait voilà c'est à dire la prison
d'abou ghraïb en irak
voilà alors vous parlez aussi des
intermittents du spectacle
michel serrault vous dit un truc vrai
vous dites les intermittents du
spectacle c'est une appellation
épouvantable il faut il devrait déjà
manifestés pour on les appelle
différemment parce qu'un intermittent du
spectacle s'adresse à un terme un peu un
peu hard hausse et alors effectivement
vous dit les choses parce que voilà vous
dit
certains figurants de cinéma refuse de
tourner trois jours pour ne pas perdre
leur assedic
voilà là on en parle d'une chose très
délicate et difficile serait passé van
trier les choses qui mail qui m'étonne
toujours tu vois tant mieux qu'on
s'occupe de la culture et qu'on donne la
possibilité à tout le monde mais qu'un
mec qui vient à lui mais une arrêt choix
gaz dans un film devient intermittent du
spectacle
et là il ya vu quelque part qu'est ce
que vous dites de 2 du peintre oui qu'il
était chez lui qui peint et canal et qui
ne vend pas ses toiles
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire je demande ce
qu'il faut faire il ya il ya quand même
des critères et il ya des métiers à
risques j'ai eu mon pantalon troué
jusqu'à 25 ans tu comprends je veux
vraiment vous dites il faut accepter le
risque inévitable du métier d'artiste
avec ce n'est pas un métier très sûrs
quoi c'est ce qu'on me dise ailleurs été
le compositeur qui ne vend pas c'est que
c'est au qatar
qu'est ce qui va faire le port est bas
alors moi je voudrais aussi qu'on
s'occupe de lui
et puis on peut on verrait les
partitions puis on essaierait de le
faire manger aussi et le compositeur et
le peintre et l'architecte qui y vend
pas ses plans etc etc
donc il ya une grande confusion là
dedans et que perf alors tout le monde
noie le poisson personnes s'entend
je te gré des sports et vivre ceux ci
vivent cela moins minable way points
alors ceci étant michel serrault vous
êtes extrêmement solidaires des victimes
des injustices vous dites suis-je de
droite
suis-je de gauche oui effectivement à
l'église de droite je préfère l'église
de gauche mais votre véritable
dichotomie à vous elle s'opère entre
croyants et incroyants dans un premier
temps plutôt contre gauche et droite et
et vous dites il faut être du côté des
pauvres
voilà ça c'est la seule chose finalement
qui doit nous mener occupons nous des
gens qu'on rencontre dans la vie il aura
pas besoin de s'expatrier très loin pour
de mêmes services
alors simplement ouvrons nos oreilles
nos yeux et puis ouvrons notre bourse
et puis essayons de faire quelque chose
mais le reste le rêve chaman ars pas
beaucoup et on vous dit un truc
formidable dit
un athée solidaire vaut mieux qu'un
cadeau qui fait rien pour les autres
ben oui ça me parait commencer par il
fait après ça bon on ira peut-être vers
autre chose mais ne commencez pas par le
bon dieu ne parlait pas du bon dieu
il faut faire des actes si vous pouvez
aider quelqu'un à côté de chez vous ou
en lozère ou n'importe où voilà n'est ce
pas mêler les candidats n'ont commencé
par sortir des soutes votre poche pour
les autres je vous êtes un vrai chrétien
vous jetez pas vrai chrétien je crois
que sans parler mais je me pose beaucoup
qu'on m'accuse d'être chrétien je suis
pas un exemple je suis pas mais je crois
que tout toutes les croyances commence
par l'espèce d'humanité de fraternité
avec les gens et basta le reste on verra
après
alors
michel serrault vous mettez aussi les
pieds dans le plat mais clé dans le
plain pied dans le plat c'est le titre
du livre va vous parler de moi dans
votre bouquin n'ont pas de trace ici
oblige à vous vous dites thierry
ardisson je le préfère dans rive droite
rive gauche que dans tout le monde en
parle
tirée à 10 ans c'est docteur jekyll et
mister hyde
c'est triste de le voir ainsi s'abîmer
vous parler de ce que je fais dans cette
émission c'est triste de voir un psy
s'abîmer c'est terrible ça que vous
disiez des choses comme ça à michel je
suis le même dans les deux emissions
mais voir quelqu'un que j'ai c'est pas
terrible parce que je suis allé il y en
a une il ya 4 millions de gens locaux
deux cent mille personnes c'est tout on
peut pas faire la même chose ou qu'ils
étaient même de ce spectacle c'est bien
qu'on peut pas faire la même chose pour
deux cent mille personnes ou pour 4
millions de gens il sait c'est qu'il
faut faire pour temps mais on les a mais
quel jeu il faut vous qu'on gérait la
crâne pour faire confiance à tous
publics c'est oui on essaye mais voilà
et j'ai dit des choses aimables quand
même à vous dit à la fin de quoi je me
mêle ce qui est cool hein je dirais que
ce livre il est fait pour rire
sérieusement oui et puis basta à
l'oreille c'est très bien votre bouquin
parce que juste après m'avoir dit que
j'étais docteur jekyll et mister hyde
oui vous vous attaquez fogiel donc ça
c'est formidable je tacle sur brigitte
bardot ah oui j'aime pas parce que
j'aime beaucoup brigitte bardot ouais
comme j'ai plus vingt ans j'ai commencé
avec elle à jouer la comédie et je les
aime beaucoup et je l'admirais beaucoup
comme comédienne comme chanteuse comme
femme magnifique une belle et maintenant
alors on s'amuse et on fait du scandale
autour d'elle les animaux et qu'elle
s'occupe des animaux commencer si vous
n'avez pas le courage de
deux de vous occuper des autres prenez
exemple sur bardon et commencé de d'être
bon avec les ânes à mon avis et vous
verrez qu'un jour vous vous intéresserez
aux autres housses mais aux hommes aux
femmes et aux enfants
donc alors basta pas de pas de jugement
rochelle ce que vous dites c'est qu'ils
l'ont manipulé pour l'amener sur le
plateau voilà avec une fois qu'elle a
été sur le plateau ils l'ont massacré
voilà qu'est ce que vous essayez de
faire avec moi la première celle là ça
c'est la mastercard que la minceur vous
dites vous dites encore des choses vous
dit l'un d'eux sous ce nom vous dit vous
dites que fogiel étaient moins arrogant
avec de longs parce que delon l'aurait
sûrement pas supporté je pense qu'il ya
de ça mais moi je dois y aller chez lui
mais j'y vais pas je vois j'ai mieux
venir ici parce que là on se comprend
ma part
alors comme vous avez dit que cette
émission était parfois nul
bah vous allez avoir droit michel
serrault à une interview nul